[Music]
good morning it's seven o'clock this is
sky news breakfast top stories today
plans to ease the pressure on the pumps
downing street is expected to allow a
temporary visa scheme for foreign htv
drivers to stop the shortage
i'm live outside a petrol station in
west london where they're queuing to get
in
despite assurances that there's no
shortage of fuel
labor pain sequia stalmer backtracks on
plans to rewrite the party rulebook
ahead of this weekend's conference we'll
talk to his deputy at half past
remembering sabine nessa hundreds attend
a vigil for the school teacher murdered
on her way to a pub in southeast london
more towns evacuated and flights
cancelled as volcanic eruptions
intensify on la palma
this is the live view from the volcano
right now as it spews lava for a sixth
day
bond is back fans prepare to be shaken
and stirred by daniel craig's final
appearance as double07
i've never regretted it it's been
tough but it's always always always
always been interesting it's always been
creatively satisfying
in the sport with jackie it's advantage
to the usa as they take on europe in the
ryder cup golf match in wisconsin
the weather today more warm sunny spells
this weekend but it's turning cooler
next week
and at quarter two we'll take you the
papers with the broadcasters gemma forte
and thomas copeland
[Music]
morning to you the government is
considering temporary measures to tackle
the shortage of hgv drivers which is
causing panic at petrol pumps and empty
shelves around the country
reports suggest the prime minister is
poised to introduce a temporary easing
of visa rules to allow more foreign
drivers into the uk
it comes as queues were seen stretching
from petrol station four courts up and
down the country yesterday
as concerns over a fuel shortage spread
well emma birchley is outside a petrol
station in west london forwards now
where it seems emma the queues are
continuing today
yes there have been queues here actually
throughout the night we know and
they're queuing on the a4 here at the
other x entrance as well but actually in
the last
10 minutes or so
one of the staff members has come out
and said no more petrol so there's
diesel but no more petrol here and
actually driving in this morning passing
four petrol stations i passed two where
every single pump had been covered over
because they'd simply
run out of petrol and that's why
ministers met yesterday
to discuss what was going to happen um
they're talking about
contingency plans so short term visas
it's been reported that maybe
as many as 5 000 part of the problem is
the pandemic people haven't been able to
take hdv tests
um but also um people haven't been able
to come to work and then there's brexit
we know that 14 000 hdv drivers from the
eu left the uk in the year to june 2020
so that all adds up let's have a little
look round here if you come and have a
look now there are fewer vehicles than
there were because if you look here at
these pumps these were all in action it
looks like there may still be a v power
fuel but actually
most of the pumps all around have
started being covered up uh they are no
longer in action and it's that kind of
picture we're seeing uh across the
country and earlier just a few minutes
ago actually i was speaking to some
people as they queued up here who voiced
their intense frustration about what's
happening
it's stupidity
that we're all queuing up
but this is my job so i have to have
diesel
that's it i'm in here for my work
i never know where it's going
so i've got to have diesel
everybody else
one person tells someone there's cues so
they go
and do it
and so on and so forth
it's interesting you're lucky you need
diesel because they've just been saying
no no petrol no petrol just diesel yeah
that's fine by me because
i've been working all night and
lots of stations have got
cars down to the next
big junction
so
i don't know why they're doing it if
they need it fine
i need mine
but
they're just thrilling to say i've got a
full tank
yeah so that was oswald is a taxi driver
he obviously really needs his fuel but
i'm i've seen people filling up little
petrol cans here maybe for their lawn
mower but you imagine it's just in case
they end up in a situation where there
simply isn't any fuel left but of course
the shortage isn't just fuel uh lorry
drivers it's also for food deliveries
and we've been hearing concerns about
the impact that might have we've already
seen shortages but particularly with uh
christmas just a few months away the
british retail consortium says this
needs to be sorted swiftly if we're not
going to find ourselves facing some
significant shortages over christmas now
the government says that hgv tests are
happening at a faster pace there are
more people carrying out those
examinations
so with the temporary visas it should be
in theory that this is eased but
certainly no easing of the people
queuing up to make sure they get some
petrol
okay emma thank you
now the labour party conference starts
in brighton today but already sakia
stama has been forced to retreat over
his attempt to rewrite the party's rule
book he's had to put reforms on hold
after a backlash from unions and party
activists
our chief political correspondent john
craig reports from brighton
the sun may have shone in brighton but
the mood on the opening day of labour's
conference is anything but sunny
zakir starmer suffered humiliation on
the eve of conference when in meetings
behind closed doors he was forced to put
his plans for party reforms on hold
after opposition from trade unions and
left wingers
sakir wants to scrap the one member one
vote system on which he and jeremy
corbyn were elected leader and returned
to an electoral college where mps unions
and activists each have a third of the
votes
his retreat has raised new questions
about his leadership
this was a golden opportunity enough for
kia to get up there and speak to the
people in this country and and tell them
what the labour party stands for tell
them what we want in terms of solutions
i think that it's an own goal it'll be a
missed opportunity and people will be
wondering why when naval gears in and
talking about rule changes
after her barnstorming performance
standing in for secure at prime
minister's questions this week deputy
leader angela rayner opens the
conference this afternoon with a speech
pledging a new deal for working people
but policy pledges are in danger of
being overshadowed
does it make or break for you it's not a
relaunch by any shape or this is a
chance i think for um me to set out what
the future looks uh like um and
again one of the things i've taken away
from
all the various discussions i've had
over the
course of this summer is people
desperately want change
but the pressure on sakir has now
increased
the labour leader may deny that this is
a make-or-break conference for him and
his leadership well there's no doubt
it's absolutely crucial as labour
attempts to mount a fight back against
boris johnson and the conservatives at a
time when the government is facing all
sorts of problems
but first sakir has to try to salvage
his party reforms
and rebuild his battered reputation
john craig sky news brighton
hundreds of people gathered in south
east london last night for a vigil in
memory of the murdered primary school
teacher sabina nessa the 28 year old was
attacked last friday as she walked to
meet a friend at a pub just five minutes
from her home her sister attended the
vigil and told crowds that her world had
been shattered
a 12 year old boy has died after being
seriously injured at an indoor ski
center officers were called to the snow
dome in tamworth yesterday to reports
that a child had been hurt the boy died
a short while later a man was also
injured
prince andrew's lawyers have accepted
that he's been served with a sexual
assault lawsuit by virginia gaffrey
she claims the duke of york sexually
assaulted her on three occasions when
she was a teenager two of which she says
occurred at the homes of convicted sex
trafficker jeffrey epstein prince andrew
has always denied the allegations
against him
the jury is yet to reach a verdict in
the r kelly sex trafficking trial
they'll resume deliberations on monday
the r b star is accused of running a
chicago-based trafficking ring with
accusations of sexual and physical abuse
dating back decades
a top boss at the chinese tech giant
huawei has left canada for the first
time and almost three years after being
detained on bank fraud charges
meng wan zhu huawei's chief financial
officer has been allowed to return to
china after reaching an agreement with
u.s prosecutors in exchange beijing has
released two canadian nationals detained
since 2018. it's a significant
breakthrough in what was becoming an
increasingly heated point of tension
between beijing and washington
now it's been six days since the
eruption of a volcano in the canary
islands but explosions are intensifying
once again as you can see from these
live pictures of cambria vieja behind me
now authorities have stepped up efforts
to evacuate more people but they're
being hampered by cancelled flights
caused by giant ash clouds
ashley huradag has the latest from la
palma
[Music]
for a tiny island this is some disaster
it descends
smoldering and spewing on la palma
its unpredictable actions have led to
predictable reactions those boarding a
fully booked ferry to neighboring
tenerife are eager to get out
i came here from another island because
i have family here and i tried to help
them because part of my family have lost
everything
my uncle lost his house
and a lot of friends and yeah he's very
sad very sad
horrible
just 15 minutes till departure but
they're still trying their luck for
tickets
where do they go now when hotel rooms
are scarce too
many of them are housing the now
homeless that number will rise too with
three more towns being evacuated as the
volcano signals further distress
sometimes gas that's building up as big
bubbles is getting close to the surface
and essentially
erupting in in a violent explosion and
they can they can produce shock waves so
the shock wave itself is is essentially
a very fast moving often moving faster
than ambient sound a change in pressure
um density and velocity as a wave coming
out from those explosions
it is no wonder why the mood has changed
the thick cloud continues to pulse from
the volcano filling the skies above the
island public health advice has changed
too wear your mask outside close your
windows and don't go out unless
necessary
hundreds of buildings have been engulfed
this house the anomaly stands freakishly
untouched the spanish prime minister is
optimistic of the island's recovery
we are all working together
what we want is to solve both the
immediate problems of the people
affected and the ones that will emerge
later
we'll reconstruct la palma and make this
an opportunity to relaunch the island
it may be considered premature to some
this element of mother nature will
change the landscape forever it may not
have taken any lives but it's burning
everything in between
ashanaharanak sky news on la palma
now germans head to the polls tomorrow
to decide who's going to replace angela
merkel as her time as chancellor comes
to an end after 16 years let's talk to
oliver moody berlin correspondent for
the times good to see you this morning i
mean it the polls seem very very tight
at the moment i mean the coalition's
inevitable is it
good morning um it is as sir alex
ferguson used to say squeaky bum time
the poles are getting exceedingly tight
and angela merkel's
conservative cdu csu alliance has pulled
to one or two percentage points
behind the social democrats um it's hard
to think of a
closer
election in germany's modern history
this close to polling day and um yes
they have germany's been ruled by
coalitions ever since um 1949 and this
time we're very likely to end up with a
three or even four-party coalition
um i mean obviously it's not that long
ago that the the greens were actually
leading the polls now they're not at the
moment but i mean clearly they're making
significant inroads and does that mean
that the whole environment agenda
is more and more important to the german
population
that's a very interesting question the
polls suggest that particularly
following the drought of 2018 and the
extreme flooding in the rhineland
in july this year the environment has
shot up to the top of the political
agenda but there's a lot of disagreement
on
what kind of sacrifices the german
public is prepared to make and whether
the best way to decarbonize is through
restricting things as the green party
tends to
favor or by
sort of stimulating the market to
develop new uh carbon cutting
technologies as the cdu and um the the
sort of more economically liberal
parties tend to go for so the
environment is a huge issue in this
election but that doesn't necessarily
favor uh the green party okay well
that's interesting looking in in because
this is tight
um
whoever becomes chancellor after angela
merkel and obviously the
few names on the list now with this
being so close but does
are we likely to see any significant
change in in direction
absolutely not
frankly um
the
contest uh between armin laschette the
leader of the cdu and ola trolls the
chancellor candidate from the social
democrats has been very much a
competition to look like angela merkel
they've been emulating her gestures
they've been borrowing her phrases
and the policy platforms that they put
forward have a few differences on um
sort of fiscal policy and taxation but
otherwise they look very much like
continuity from the miracle era and both
sides are trying not to frighten the
horses and to to make it clear that
merkel's legacy will be safe in their
hands i mean is there a sense that armin
has
perhaps not resonating with voters in
the in the same way as as perhaps uh mr
schultz
that's putting it mildly um there was a
poll released yesterday where german
voters were asked who they would pick
as their chancellor if they could and
lashed actually came forth behind
not just the spd but the greens and the
economically liberal free democrats and
his favorability ratings are behind
schultz by longshore on almost every
single conceivable
point um he's spectacularly unpopular
it's hard hard to think of a more
unpopular candidate than cdu since it
was founded in 1949.
okay well we shall watch with interest
tomorrow oliver good to talk to you
thank you thank you
now after near endless delays many
feared they'd never get to see the
latest bond film but they'll never say
never again because it's finally in
cinemas this coming thursday and for
your eyes only
our arts and entertainment correspondent
katie spencer has spoken to daniel craig
and bond producer barbara broccoli
fans have needed a stiff martini waiting
for daniel craig's much delayed final
outing as bond
but now it's here
real life got in the way and delayed
this coming out how has that process
been we had to kind of have to be kind
of like well there's nothing we could do
thankfully um
[Music]
both mgm and universal held their nerve
and we didn't see this slip into a
streaming service and we got here and
we're going to actually get into the
cinemas which is just
a joyous thing we know that amazon uh of
buying mgm does that mean that we might
see a sort of spin-off tv show well i
don't think so we have not wanted to do
spin-offs so i think that's our position
they certainly have told us that um
that the films will will be theatrical
films in the future and we'll see what
happens
there's something i need to tell you i
bet there is
are you pleased that you did say yes to
the job i've never regretted it it's
been
tough but it's always always always
always been interesting it's always been
creatively satisfying you were quite
open from the start that one of the
worst parts has been the the level of
press intrusion that you've had
from where where we were 15 years ago
we've had things like the leveson
inquiry and uh the newspapers saying
that they will adhere to certain codes
of conduct
i was going to say i mean do you think
anything's changed or is it the nature
of the beast of having this role i'd be
perfectly honest i couldn't deal with it
but but it's it is it is
part of the nature of the beast and you
have to sort of accept it i try and keep
a very private life so that
that's my sort of
that's my sort of line in the sand i
suppose
walking away from double 07 hasn't been
as easy for the bond star as newspapers
might have made out this was his last
day on set
i've got up every morning and i've had
the chance to work
um with you guys and that has been one
of the greatest honors of my life are
you quite excited at the thought of
putting your feet up having a bacon
sandwich i'd do that anyway i bust my
ankle on this one how many weeks in
six weeks in maybe yeah yeah which is
sort of like ah well there you go
at the end of spectre that was one of
the reasons i thought i had to stop
because i just thought i was
not physically able to do it anymore
[Music]
the next james bond then is it is it in
your head or is it a lot more fluid oh
god it's not in my head at all as i say
i'm in denial i don't want to think
about it and i'm not going to think
about it as far as i'm concerned daniel
craig is james bond end of story how do
you both hope that people will remember
the daniel craig bond
that we took it somewhere that we that
we did something with it that that that
was
that
it had some meaning when people think of
them fondly in the future that's just
all gravy you know thank you so much
thank you
i can't wait i cannot wait and let's
have a look at the weather for you and
it has been a warm and dry month
exceptionally so but it's going to turn
cooler and unsettled next week most
places having a mild and cloudy start
bit of drizzle few fog patches going to
be windier and wetter across the far
north of scotland now the skies will
brighten to leave a largely fine and dry
day best of the warm sunshine for east
wales the midlands northeast scotland it
will be sunnier across southern england
a little bit later on
now the labour party conference begins
later on today by the seaside but it's
already been a rocky start for the
leader shakir stamina who's backed down
on his voting reform proposals after
criticism from within the party well
let's talk to the deputy leader angela
rayner who joins me now it's good to see
you this morning but why is sakia
capitulated on this morning
well what catered out was a consultation
about how we can look at our party and
make sure that we're a party that's
looking to government and you know i've
never known a conference yet where we
haven't had a little bit of our dubai
certainly at the start about where we
see the direction of the party going and
i'm sure we'll have plenty of that
debate going into conference and that's
the right thing to do so i don't really
see it as you know care backing down
kier said that he wanted to have a
consultation it was right that he set
the tone for that and it's right that
you know we're taking the issues forward
that matter people and that you know i'm
talking about a new deal for working
people i'll be setting out that in my
conference speech later this afternoon
and that's what i want to do is get on
the topic of how we improve people's
lives in this country but i mean he's he
set out a 10 000 word
essay didn't he on the reforms he wanted
to bring in that's what we were told
that's all gone by the by now which i
mean leaves people i mean understandably
so saying well what does this tell us
about his leadership if he can't even
push through what he thinks is essential
for the future of the party
i could tell you didn't read his essay
because he didn't mention the rule
change once it knows
well well i can tell you i could give
you the summary the executive summary
was he was setting out a program which
is about how we can focus on you know
things have got very difficult for
people in this country and it's because
of the the failed promises of the
conservative government and it's about
the alternative to that which is about
giving people secure work um you know
providing good public services about
looking after people's mental well-being
as well as their physical well-being
about rebuilding the country that looks
at working people and the people that
create wealth and therefore gives them
more of that share so stops the zero
hour contracts stops insecure work
provides a minimum floor so that people
actually go to work to live rather than
live for work and that's the important
differential is that we're on the side
of working people whereas the
conservatives have shown themselves to
be taxing them now cutting universal
credit freezing the personal allowance
and all the while living you know living
costs are going up because of the
government's failures on things like
energy and the government's failures on
being able to provide you know the
skilled htv drivers so that we've got
those supplies of food and fuel and you
know people have started to panic by
fuel and i would urge people not to do
that um because that will only make the
situation worse but this is of the
government's own doing and their
failures
i mean it's fair to say the government
is is facing big problems at the minute
and yet you know the let's be fair the
labour party has been pretty silent on
these issues i mean very few people
watching today are going to
download and try to read fourteen
thousand words from sakiya stamina to
see what what labour's position is on
that
well all i can say is that if you didn't
watch pmqs on wednesday then get it on
catch up because i gave the government
what for on these issues you know our
shadow chancellor wrote as the chair of
the select committee warning them about
the fact that they'd lost the facilities
for our gas storage which has had a
significant impact on the situation we
face now these are
problems that the government has faced
for a while they knew it was coming and
have failed to respond it's a theme that
we have with this government they
constantly do things at the last minute
at the last possible point and create
the crisis in the first place so you
know we have been urging the government
to look at these issues but you know
once again boris johnson and his
government have basically decided to
have a laissez faire attitude and hope
that things will just fix itself well it
hasn't fixed itself and their policies
have come home to roost for the british
public
well this is a chance as sakia said in a
sky news interview this is a chance to
set out what the future looks like well
the future looks like the labour party
being led by someone who is at least i
mean you're going to say wrongly but but
perceived by many now as being pretty
weak
i don't think the public see care as
weak actually what they see is somebody
who's very serious who's very forensic
and who tackles the government in a very
constructive way now some people like
the bombastic way in which i uh tackle
the government i'm more of a john
prescott type figure and you know that's
just my style care has a different style
but that doesn't mean to say that he's
not incredibly passionate and forensic
and has managed to you know many times
carers raise the issues of concern and
he's been proven right but he doesn't do
the punch and judy type of theatrical
politics he does the serious these are
serious issues facing our country child
poverty is record high people are
waiting for cancer treatment and have
been denied it you know we have a crisis
now on our four courts we have problems
with fuel and energy and we have cuts
that have impacted on working families
and care is raising those issues and i
think that's right to do that this
conference is about also putting forward
what we would do differently and what
our priorities are
yeah but if you're going to win the next
election whenever that is you know 23 or
24 you've got to have someone who's
going to appeal to the electorate and
there are questions around that now
whereas i mean you said in an interview
just the other day you wouldn't turn
down the opportunity to be party leader
which in itself is a controversial thing
to say
well no you see the problem is is that
everybody fixates on would you ever want
to be party leader and i said it's been
an absolute honor and a privilege first
of all to be elected as a member of
parliament for ashton underline and the
people that elected me there but also a
great privilege to be elected the deputy
leader of the labour party that gave me
so many opportunities in the last labour
government that has got me to where i am
today so i take that as an absolute
honour to do it and i think a lot of the
times especially when women get asked
this question we say oh no no that's not
what we want and it makes us look like
you know we're not ambitious i want
every woman in this country to be
ambitious but my ambition and i'm very
clear on this is to get kirsten into
number 10 because this country cannot
face more of conservative broken
promises and lies and for me to be
deputy prime minister by kirsten aside
making the difference because i was a
home carer i've done a manual job i've
you know i've had to worry about my
heating bills and looking after my
children and that is what many people in
this country face today and they want to
see us coming up with the solutions and
i'm passionate about making sure that
they see that both myself and care are
going to go into government and make
their lives better and enable them to be
more fulfilled at work and to have those
minimum standards that mean they don't
have to worry about whether they're
going to have a shift next week or
whether they're going to have to choose
between heating or eating
angela rainer it's good to talk to you
thank you
now more than 60 000 fans will be at the
tottenham hotspur stadium tonight as
anthony joshua puts his heavyweight
world titles on the line against
mandatory challenger alexander usyk
jackie caught up with her relaxed aj
earlier this week and started by asking
what sort of night he's expecting
night i'm expecting to come out walk
through that tunnel sixty thousand
people swing
singing sweet caroline
uh usyk waiting in the ring
people singing his name people singing
my name
you know the intro michael buffer
announcing let's get ready to rumble
fans going crazy the first bell goes
it's such a beautiful sound it's uh in
the gym it's normally a buzzer if you
know boxing it's only like a little
buzzer that goes up in the gym but that
bell sound ding ding round one is
underway
um the lights are just shining on that
ring everything around you is like black
it's dark
the lights are shining on that ring and
it's like it's a phenomenal feeling
really phenomenal feeling
do you think people don't always give
you credit for your boxing ability given
what you've achieved
well
i i never look at it like that you know
well look there's 60 000 people coming
out so they must like something about
what i'm doing
but i don't want to be
like
searching for
so much love i just hope people
appreciate boxing as a whole the whole
undercard me
it's going to be a good night boxing um
underrated overrated valued
at least certain people value i think
let's not focus on the negative about
the people that don't value what i do i
like to focus on people that do value
what i do
how do you deal with fight night itself
you know obviously there's pressure but
you always look relaxed but when you
wake up in the morning do you have
butterflies are you excited
so you start with visualization from
training camp putting yourself in that
scenario mentally so when you kind of
wake up look no matter how you feel
no matter how you feel tired achy um
now i i go in i know sparring isn't the
opponent but there's times when i'll go
in and i've got four or five guys
waiting to spar me and i may not feel
100 but the ultimate thing is i get out
the other end i always perform i go
there and on fight night your adrenaline
whether you've got a headache you've got
a bad foot a bad hand whatever it may be
the environment just overtakes you and
makes you feel at ease that you just
feel like there's nothing else that
matters in the world right now except
for discipline that's going on and to
have the fans back finally what does
that mean for me it's it just it makes
me humble because in a way that i just
got to dedicate myself to the craft so i
can go out there and perform for uh all
these fans that come out i don't take it
for granted it's not like i've ticked
that box
like forget it now i'm happy i've done
what i've had to do um i fought in front
of x amount of people i actually look at
it and i'm like why i need to make sure
i practice and i work hard because
i want to give these guys value you know
what i mean so that's how i pay them
back
did you know that reducing pollution
outside of school can help stop toxic
air getting trapped in our classrooms
it will be a mild and cloudy start with
spots of drizzle and some fog patches
the skies will brighten to leave a
largely dry and warm day the best of the
sunshine for east wales the midlands and
northeast scotland cloudier towards the
northwest with patchy light rain and
windier here too
taking a look at the daily air quality
index where levels of air pollution are
banded from one being low to 10 being
very high air pollution levels are
expected to remain low today despite the
light winds across the south
the air quality report sponsored by
philips air purifiers
well time for the papers once again with
gemma forte and thomas copeland good to
see you let's kick straight off with the
guardian gemma um a make or break
conference for sakia
not according to angela rainer
no not according to angela rainer but i
think
i think it probably is let's be honest
so i'm someone that is just desperate
for the opposition to get it together at
this stage i know it's been difficult
for starman from the point of view that
he's been in opposition during a global
pandemic it is uh not so easy to be
criticizing a government at a time when
everybody needs you to come together
that said there's been open goal after
open goal and i feel like labour have
missed it um every time every time you
turn around and you're like okay where's
the opposition they're arguing amongst
themselves and that has to end so this
is his opportunity now to tell everybody
what it is he wants to do now typically
again this has been maybe overshadowed
by the fact that one of the things he
wants to do is put a last-minute bid
through to push how you elect leadersh
leaders
and i think that needs to be put to one
side he's also written this big opus
this big sort of manual if you like his
philosophy his um his thought process
behind what he wants to do he's been
criticized for that that i don't get
because we have a prime minister who
arguably doesn't put any thought behind
anything and just blast us through in a
very um
uh sort of knee-jerk way um so i do
think we need government to be looking
forward in strategizing and doing the
dull stuff uh to an extent but we do
also need some bite-size slogans to an
extent that's what we're up against the
conservative party is so good at that
and the electorate need to know okay
this is what they stand for this is what
they're gonna do and i think if he
doesn't do that you look at andre lorena
and she has a vivaciousness and she has
a ferocity that perhaps he doesn't have
and that might cut through in a better
way um well let's have a look at angie
lorena in a bit more detail thomas she's
apart from talking to us which obviously
was top of her list she's done an
interview with the times
yeah that's right her second favorite
interviewer i'm sure stephen um if if
stormers conference speech doesn't go
well the good news i spoke for angela
rainer she's waiting in the rings after
a barnstormer of a uh of a pmq's earlier
in the week against dominic grabbed
she's featured here in the times
in an interview that is well worth a
read certainly you'll come away with it
maybe appreciating a lot more about your
own childhood the overriding sense you
get is just the scale of the challenges
that she faced as a young person council
stayed in stockport uh care for her
bipolar mother pregnant at 15 left
school at 16
thrown out of her home by her father i
mean to be a kind of fully functioning
member of society as that's impressive
enough not to mention deputy leader of
the labour party
and to have as the as the interview
points out a cocktail named after you in
the house of commons and the most
profound part i actually think is she
talks uh very powerfully about this
sense of emotional poverty and how
that's distinct from any sort of
financial poverty and the effect that's
had on her to this day i think you know
there are definitely people who might
read it who would take a second look at
angela rayner perhaps especially you
know um under the circumstances that
kierstarm are the area in which he's
found himself most difficult to
communicate with the public and
certainly the policy and i kind of agree
with what gem is saying there but also
that emotional connection hasn't really
been made he mainly went on piers
morgan's life stories earlier on in the
year attempting to make those kind of
connections and he has a very powerful
story as well but i just haven't you
know hasn't seemed to cut through in the
same way politically angela rainer's
shown herself to be extraordinarily
astute she's sort of negotiated her way
out of a demotion
after that hartlepool by-election into a
promotion
um i wonder you know there will
certainly be maybe she has a team or
supporters or people behind her might be
whispering in her ear around springtime
i think if kirst armour hasn't started
to dramatically turn things around by
that stage that would be the time when
she makes those moves i mean i watched
that interview with her
you you conducted just there stephen and
obviously she's got all the right
answers when it comes to to to putting
her support behind keir starmer at this
stage um
you know give it six months will things
be a little bit different
um it's interesting i mean she certainly
does have that appeal of being a
a real person if you like someone we you
know is more relatable
yeah oh yeah i think it's that it's
having empathy and i think that's what's
been lacking in politics for a long time
i think you know when it wasn't during
the pandemic when there was the feeding
hungary children issue
and it just seemed unfathomable to most
normal people that that wasn't being
looked after um so yes it would be nice
to have politicians who understand what
it is like to worry about their bills
rather than
the current club
no i was just going to say it strikes me
that rainer's not afraid to to kind of
make a bold stand on things i i read
cure stormers or red good bar of st
kearstarmas uh opus so it's 35 pages
long 14 000 words the problem is that i
could i couldn't disagree with it or
think of a single person who could
possibly disagree with it you know the
the the problem with um you know you
always know when something's a bit of a
political platitude when when nobody
could possibly take the opposite opinion
i wonder if rainer isn't as afraid to
take a stand perhaps as afraid to decide
who her voters are going to be that's
the problem that kierstarm has to deal
with over the next number of months and
years who are his voters because
maintaining the kind of voter coalition
that he's currently trying to balance is
probably nigh on impossible he's decide
who he needs to go for and who needs to
drop i wonder if raider might be a
little bit more cutthroat there
interesting
let's let's move on to the express
should we
um the vigil we saw last night uh for
sabine i mean
huge vigil actually gemma
yes and unsurprisingly it's absolutely
tragic
she had a whole life ahead of her i'm
watching her parents her family speak
her sister it's horrendous absolutely
horrendous you know she was a daughter
and a sister a teacher to a year one
class of primary school children and i
have to say how do you break it to them
what has happened here you know when
you're in year one if i can remember
that far back you love your teacher
desperately so it's it's tragic on all
front and of course it follows the death
of sarah everard and we have to
do something about male violence it is
not acceptable
of course and it's tragic and i know
that
everybody there lighting a candle and
expressing their feeling on social media
you know there is this huge outpouring
but how do we solve it what do we do and
it is another issue that has to be
addressed sooner rather than later
so that
no more young women lose their lives
when all they're doing is walking home
that's it
yeah it's impossible to argue with that
let's
thomas can we have a look at at the mail
please and and margaret keenan
the first person in the world i think to
get a boo to get a fisa jab has now had
her booster
yeah that's right and from framana i
just had to find that northern irish
connection we managed to wriggle our way
in everywhere yeah so margaret keenan's
91 grandmother has now got her booster
job so she was the first person outside
of clinical trials in the world to
receive her initial job way back it was
last december so she's been in for her
booster jobs this week i think thirty
five thousand three and
three hundred fifty thousand excuse me
three hundred and fifty thousand people
have had their third booster job
i i i'm
quizzical though because uh it's gonna
be really important for the government
really important for the nhs to ensure
that these booster jobs continue through
the winter i haven't heard nearly as
much about it as my concern i mean it's
been difficult enough making sure that
that everybody is vaccinated especially
with some of those younger cohorts um
the likes of kind of my age group it's
been more difficult to get
you know the vaccinations into those age
groups will need to ensure that the same
kind of level of intensity is the word
excitement right novelty that public
push advertising is maintained getting
the booster jobs into the winter because
it might well be the case that covert is
like a number of other vaccines in that
actually you know it's kind of a
three-shot vaccine maybe a better way to
describe a booster is kind of your third
shot and i know there's some
disagreement about that across different
sides of the atlantic what way that
should be phrased the reality is though
you know it is in the public interest if
people can get that third booster shot
let's try to keep up that sense of
intensity whether it is you know getting
pop-up vans here there and everywhere
free ice creams free donuts whatever it
is let's try to make sure that you know
what we maintain the same level of
excitement about getting your third shot
as the first two because that's a really
effective way to make sure we don't have
to bother with any restrictions further
lockdowns into the winter you know get
in there and get your booster i'll be
queuing up from iowa because i'm
entitled to one thankfully uh we'll just
finish off we've got about 30 seconds
gemma to the news which has made me
smile of the last set thank heavens
russell t davis is coming back to save
doctor who
he is indeed he was there um in charge
of the bbc's flagship science fiction
show back when it was christopher
eccleston in 2005 then when it was david
tennant and he is back he's going to be
handed back the baton obviously
well in my opinion he's a genius anybody
who saw it's a sin recently i hope you
enjoyed it as much as i did and if you
didn't watch it the writing is perfect
so it'll be fascinating to see what he
comes up with yes and fascinating to see
who he brings in as the new doctor
cannot wait till that all happens lovely
[Music]
you